the best way for people to get happier
immediately
is to think in sort of three steps the
first is do the work
and to do the work you need to you need
self-knowledge you need understanding
and
maybe that comes from your religious
practice maybe that comes from you know
reading a happiness book about the
science of happiness maybe that comes
from sitting at your grandmother's knee
and writing out everything she says for
a week do the work the second is to
practice it in your life you know people
if you can't just read a book about golf
and become a better golfer you actually
have to golf you have to learn and then
you have to golf and and happiness is a
hands-on business by practicing the
habits of happiness faith family friends
and work um loving other people
intensively propulsively and then the
last is really the most important which
is you got to share it you have to teach
others you know what i'm trying to do is
i'm trying to create a happiness
movement of a nation of happiness
professors one two three understand
practice share that's the secret